there was a a woman I guess a priestess
you'd call her she was in the Church of
England and she said she's she's
pretending to be a priest and she she
said that abortion can be fine it can be
it can be healthc care as a Christian
you are you are in the name of your
faith defending the human sacrifice of
little babies if we can't agree on that
political issue that that is something
that a Christian must oppose well then I
guess we can't be involved in politics
there's so many people that actually
they are Christians but they are are
accepting what is happening in the
Nations what is happening in their in
their cities whether you are a Christian
and you're follower of Christ or you are
no you cannot be larm you cannot be
saying like I am a Christian but you
know what because I don't want drama and
I don't want you know my church or my or
my place to be involved in this I just
going to agree with with what they are
saying you canot be look larm